[Applaudissements]
l'univers est-il statique et il en
expansion perpétuelle et continuera-t-il
à se diluer inlassablement au contraire
l'univers va-t-il se répondre et en un
big crunch c'est-à-dire un effondrement
complet sur lui-même en somme quelle est
notre destin cosmique
c'est finalement assez récemment que les
astrophysiciens ont commencé à répondre
à certaines de ces questions des
réponses partielles qui non loin de
repousser l'inconnu appeltans fait à de
nouvelles questions et soulève de
nouveaux mystères on parle aujourd'hui
d'un secteur sombre de l'univers une
partie de l'univers que l'on sait être
là mais dont on ne connaît pas la nature
pour vous conter l'histoire de ce côté
obscur de l'univers il faut en fait
revenir 100 ans en arrière en 1915
albert einstein postule sa théorie de la
relativité générale qui décrit la
gravitation la gravitation cette force
qui fait que si je lâche une pomme la
pomme va tomber sur le sol que vos deux
pieds sont bien accrochés sur la surface
terrestre ou encore que la terre tourne
autour du soleil
cette force elle y est décrite comme une
manifestation de la déformation de
l'espace temps qu'est ce que c'est
l'espace temps c'est l'idée que si l'on
veut repéré un événement dans le monde
il faut donner 3 coordonnées des espaces
et une coordonnée de temps pour albert
einstein l'espace et le temps sont
indissociables et forment ce que l'on
pourrait appeler la trame de l'espace
temps alors tout objet massif va
déformer cet espace temps comme une
balle posé sur un drap tendu et tout
petite déformation de l'espace temps va
mettre en mouvement les objets qui le
composent
revenant l'exemple de la pomme par
exemple la terre est très massives
elle creuse un puits dans l'espace-temps
la pomme que je lâche va tomber au fond
du puits et y rester piégés alors quand
albert einstein publie sa théorie de la
relativité générale
il gère tout de suite à comprendre
quelles sont les possibles destin de
l'univers prédit par sa théorie de la
gravitation
en fait il n'ya que deux possibles
l'univers est soit en expansion soit en
contraction mais expansion contraction
ce sont deux possibilités qui ne
plaisent absolument pas à einstein à ses
contemporains qui croit dur comme fer
un univers qui serait statique figé et
immuable qui n'évoluerait pas dans le
temps serait toujours le même et
n'aurait donc ni commencement ni fin
alors voyons que sa propre théorie ne
peut prédire l'univers statique auquel
il croit albert einstein décide de jouer
les comptables et d'équilibrer les
comptes cosmique
si l'univers a trop de masse et qu'il va
donc se contracter sous l'effet de sa
main on peut ajouter un petit paramètres
une constante dans les équations qui va
contrebalancer exactement cet effet de
la gravité et permettre à l'univers non
plus d'être en contraction mais de
pouvoir rester à l'équilibré
cette constante c'est la constante
cosmologique d'einstein
en fait elle n'est pas très
satisfaisantes et c'est une observation
dans les années 20 qui va complètement
bouleverser notre perception du monde
cette observation c'est celle de beule
et le maître qui vont découvrir que les
galaxies autour de nous s'éloigne tout
nous fuit avec une vitesse d'autant plus
grande qu'elle sont loin alors le
verdict est sans appel
si nous croyons aux principes
copernicien c'est à dire que nous
n'occupons pas une place privilégiée
dans l'univers que l'univers et le maine
en tout point et dans toutes les
directions
alors nécessairement la fuite des
galaxies signifie que l'univers est en
expansion pour comprendre ce qu'est
l'expansion cosmique on utilise souvent
une image celle d'un gâteau pépites de
chocolat que l'on mettrait au four alors
le gâteau sous l'effet de la levure va
enfler enflé gonflé il est en expansion
les petites pépites de chocolat sur ce
gâteau qui sont les galaxies vous l'avez
compris ses pépites de chocolat avant
tout s'éloigner les unes des autres
car la trame sur laquelle elles sont
posées c'est à dire la pâte à gâteau est
elle-même en expansion
alors c'est un fait l'univers est en
expansion
il n'est pas statique et la constante
cosmologique d'einstein n'est plus
nécessaire il décide de la retirer de
ces équations et la qualifierait dit on
de plus grande erreur de sa vie une
erreur peut-être mais en fait cette
constante ne disparaît pas complètement
elle réapparaît régulièrement et finit
même par faire un retour définitif il y
a une vingtaine d'années dans les années
90 quand une nouvelle observation vient
encore une fois bouleversé la donne
on découvre que non seulement l'univers
est en expansion mais il est en fait en
expansion accélérée de plus en plus
rapide
cette observation elle est totalement
contre intuitive la gravité d'une force
attractive elle devrait ralentir
l'expansion cosmique et pourtant ce que
l'on observe c'est bien que l'univers
est en expansion de façon accélérée et
n'ont pas ralenti alors il faut trouver
quel est le moteur de cette accélération
cosmique
il pourrait s'agir de la constante
cosmologique d'einstein c'est vrai mais
ce n'est pas le seul scénario possible
d'autres options sont envisagées on
pense par exemple
que peut-être l'univers serait remplie
dans fluide d'énergie sombre qui
auraient des propriétés physiques par
exemple une pression négative qui lui
donnerait un effet finalement répulsif
l' inverse de la gravité il permettrait
donc à l'univers d'accélérer son
expansion
c'est la première option une deuxième
serait que notre théorie de la
gravitation la relativité générale qui
est si bien tester si bien connu à notre
échelle ne soit peut-être pas la bonne
théorie de la gravitation à plus grande
échelle à l'échelle de l'univers
elle aurait peut-être besoin d'être
modifié d'être amendée enfin une autre
possibilité pour et est que le principe
copernicien n'est peut-être pas vérifié
que peut-être nous occupons en fait une
place privilégiée dans l'univers ce
serait le cas par exemple si nous
vivions au centre d'un grand vide
cosmique alors répondre à ces questions
trouvent et le moteur de l'accélération
cosmique est vraiment l'une des plus
grandes inconnues
si ce n'est peut-être la plus grande
inconnue de la cosmologie aujourd'hui et
c'est finalement exactement l'objet de
mon travail je suis astrophysicienne et
je participe à la préparation d'une
mission spatiale qui s'appelle la
mission euclide qui sera lancée par l'
agence spatiale européenne dans trois
ans et la france est d'ailleurs l'un des
principaux contributeurs à cette mission
le cniid
ce télescope spatial va pouvoir observer
environ 2 milliards de galaxies
sur les dix derniers milliards d'années
d'évolution de l'univers alors clide
c'est déjà une prouesse technologique
on va envoyer une caméra infrarouge la
plus grande jamais envoyé dans l'espace
on va envoyer une caméra optique qui a
une précision telle avec 600 millions de
pixels que imaginez si on l'a placé à
marseille on pourrait détecter pas moins
qu'une mouche sur un ballon de foot au
parc des princes
euclide c'est aussi une prouesse
informatique on va avoir une quantité de
données très importantes à traiter sur
des supercalculateurs pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée c'est environ 170
pétaoctets de données
donc si on stocker toutes ces données
sur des disques durs qu'on s'amusait à
empiler les disques durs à faire une
très grande pile cette pile elle
atteindrait 2,6 km de haut c'est à dire
environ 7 empailleur state building les
uns sur les autres
euclide c'est aussi une prouesse
observationnelles une prouesse théorique
car on cherche à observer et à modéliser
des effets qui sont très fins et qui
pose un nombre de défis considérables
avec ce projet cette mission spatiale
on espère être capable de détecter
d'étudier quel est le moteur de
l'accélération cosmique et pour cela
nous aurons deux outils à notre
disposition le premier outil ce sera de
cartographier les galaxies c'est-à-dire
de repérer comment les galaxies sont
distribués dans l'univers et comment
cette distribution de galaxies évolué
avec le temps
ainsi on pourra savoir si la constante
cosmologique est une constante si
peut-être elle dépend du temps au
contraire et dans ce cas là le moteur de
l'accélération cosmique pourrait être un
fluide d'énergie sombre un deuxième
outil que l'on va utiliser sera non
seulement de cartographier les galaxies
mais aussi de mesurer leur forme
car l'univers est comme une loupe géante
les rayons lumineux qui le traversent
vont être déviés à cause de l'univers
lui-même de toute la masse de l'univers
cet effet est un effet qui est purement
gravitationnelle est donc mesurer les
déformations des galaxies c'est à dire
mesurer l'effet de loupe cosmique nous
permet justement de tester la
gravitation et on l'espère peut-être de
découvrir des anomalies des petits
indices qui nous permettrait de dire que
peut-être la théorie de la relativité
générale a besoin d'être modifié à
l'échelle de l'univers alors
je vous donne rendez-vous dans quelques
années pour découvrir ensemble les
résultats de cette mission au cniid
découvrir quel est le moteur de
l'accélération cosmique
s'agit-il d'un fluide d'énergie sombre
qui bannirait l'univers s'agit-il d'une
manifestation du fait que la relativité
générale a besoin d'être modifié à
l'échelle de l'univers ou peut-être
s'agit-il tout simplement de la
constante cosmologique cette constante
kane stein avait pourtant initialement
introduite par erreur pour des raisons
qui ne sont plus valables aujourd'hui
répondre à ces questions c'est
comprendre l'histoire de notre univers
comprendre nos origines mais aussi notre
destin cosmique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]